[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Leilani.
I'm a fifth year PhD
student here in CSAIL.
I work on explanatory
artificial intelligence.
I'm interested in
processes and methods
to make sure that machines
can explain themselves,
especially when they
get into errors.
My long term research is that
all machines, all processes,
even opaque processes like
machine learning systems,
will have the ability
to explain themselves;
they can be challenged in
an adversarial proceeding
if they do something
wrong; and also they'll
be able to communicate
with people,
so when we have humans
and machines working
on tasks together, they'll
be able to communicate
a common language.
I'm at the last stages
of my PhD research,
and I'm looking to evaluate
the methods I've been building
for the last couple of years.
So we hired on a UROP to do
some simulations for the project
and then work on incorporating
my methods into the simulation
to prove that it's
accurate, to prove that it
works in this environment.
So you have a vision system
that basically sees that.
Then you have some car
that's at some angle here.
And if it's at
enough of an angle,
you basically want the brakes
engaged as well as the gas.
So we want them to, basically,
have some sort of conversation
back and forth very quickly,
because they're never supposed
to be on at the same time.
If you were going to
have a rule-based system,
it would say, OK this
is absolutely wrong.
But if you have this
conversation between parts,
and maybe even a planner,
then it should come up with,
yeah, you have to
hold both of them.
And then you can proceed
forward once this turns green.
Once we pick the
simulation, I can see how
verbose my explanation will be.
Because you don't want something
that's too long and too hard
to process if you're making
this real time decision.
Can a week be good for you?
Eleven to--
--twelve on Wednesdays?
Yeah.
Yeah, works for me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Divya
Shanmugam, and I
am a PhD student in the Clinical
and Applied Machine Learning
Group.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The lab that I'm in broadly
focuses on machine learning
and health care, but
what I'm excited about
is machine learning
on unreliable data.
What is the best you can
do with data sets that
are maybe not labeled
correctly, or have
noise in their features,
or that kind of thing?
Those are the problems
that I focus on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm sort of a night
person, and so the mornings
are a lot of paper
reading and slower tasks,
and then the afternoon is filled
with meetings or more coding.
There's an organization
in the department
for the graduate
women in Course 6.
It's called GW6, and
one of the events
that it focused on
running this year
was a summit to celebrate
the women in academia
in the department and
connect people across years.
I worked with a set
of women across years
to put it together.
So we're doing a walk through of
the building before the event,
and we're just
trying to make sure
that everything we think
is going to be there
is there and just previewing
what the event might look like.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi my name is Harini, and my
research focuses on the ways
that machine learning
tools interact with people.
This can mean
anything from the ways
that people are involved in
the data collection process
and how that can lead
to negative consequences
to the ways that we can
build machine learning tools
to better serve end users.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Natalie is another PhD
student in computer science.
Natalie and I have
actually worked together
on several projects,
and it's really great
to have someone to
collaborate with.
Some of the things that we work
on are related to our research
and others are related
to side projects
that we're both interested in.
Something that we've both been
working on over the past year
is this YouTube series
called ML Tidbits.
--what exactly
people mean when they
talk about false positives,
or false negatives,
or true positives,
or true negatives.
The goal is to teach
machine learning concepts
in a really
accessible way that's
understandable to
a broad audience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There are a lot of talks
that happen around CSAIL.
It's really nice to be
able to go to these,
because they're often from
areas that you don't necessarily
encounter in your own
everyday research.
It's a nice way to break
up the normal stuff that we
do every day and learn
about research that's
happening, both from
students here at MIT,
from students elsewhere who are
visiting, from other faculty
in other departments.
The talk that we went
to on data and feminism
was by Catherine
D'Ignazio, who's
a new professor in the
urban planning department.
Her research is
also really related
to computer science
and data science.
So that was really interesting
for me to see the ways
that computer science and
the things that I'm doing
might apply to other fields
and other applications.
--intellectual history
that we inherit today
and that we can draw from and
use in our work going forward.
There are a lot of fun social
gatherings here in CSAIL.
One of the favorite things
that we do is Muffin Monday.
At 5:00 PM on Mondays, we
go up to the top floor,
and basically any
CSAIL graduate student
can have a free baked good,
and chat with friends,
and things like that.
Muffin Monday is awesome.
People come from all around
Stata to get these muffins.
Free food events are sort of
a staple of graduate student
culture in the department.
It's a good place to spend
10 or 15 minutes catching up
with people who aren't
necessarily on your floor
or in your research area, and
the pastries are pretty good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In our group, we have
group meeting every week.
We order lunch, and
usually one or two people
talk about something
they've been working on
or give a talk if they're
trying to practice a talk.
Sometimes people talk
about preliminary ideas
or go through things
on the whiteboard.
It's basically an opportunity
for people to bounce ideas off
of others in the group and get
feedback on things that they're
working on.
It's nice to get
perspective on the thing
that you're working on
from a range of people
with different backgrounds
and different expertises.
So let's start with
this project, which
is about data
augmentation to help
with one-shot medical
image segmentation.
Now, in this particular
project, the medical images
that we're looking at are
magnetic resonance images,
or MRIs.
If you've never seen one before,
this is what they look like.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Nowadays, there's no in
vivo objective biomarker
for diagnosis.
Well, photons can
actually provide
an alternative architecture
for quantum computing.
If you have a lot of data,
extracting useful information
will take a lot of human hours.
Silicon photonics
is CMOS-compatible,
so we don't have to
reinvent the wheel.
Automation, sensors everywhere,
no people on the floor.
So if something breaks, we need
to find out really quickly.
This takes the output of
some opaque mechanism, which
could be anything from
the vision system of a car
or possibly a
planner of a vehicle
that may be proprietary
because the company wants
to keep that secret.
Then this reasonableness
monitor provides an output
of both a judgment, so it says
whether the intended behavior
is reasonable or not, and also
provides an explanation of why.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Obviously being at MIT
and in CSAIL there's
a lot of pressure.
But I've been able to make
a lot of great friends,
and what's nice about
being a graduate student
is you have a very
flexible schedule.
I really love coffee,
so I try and take
a coffee break every few
days and go out with friends.
So Harini, and Divya,
and I will occasionally
go and get coffee and
just chat about things.
It's a nice excuse
to get out of lab
and to not only update
your friends about research
but also your life
surrounding that research
and maintain that
support network,
because I think graduate school
can be isolating sometimes.
Having those moments where
you're connecting with friends
can be really nice.
I also find CSAIL to
be very collaborative.
At other universities I
been or in other workplaces,
I would work mainly
in isolation.
But what's nice about being
here is I can just turn my head
and ask my colleague a question.
People are always willing to
help, and chat about research,
and collaborate.
It's just a very nice
welcoming environment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]